να χθετε κάρκος να μάθιστε ο πολόιαν καιξερωγο να πληρώνει τον βλέπω ν δημιογήζεις κάτι
που θα έχει έναντράστο κστην κιρωνία με το κάτι ιο μαζικώ να έρχονται τα παιδιάστι
θρασαν να οκτίσουμε να τική παιδιά κάτι που δεν έχουμε ασθανησί να αρχοντε ξένεινα αξιοποιούν
τις χαρικές υχικές που έχουμε εδώ οι οποίες υίναιτοερά και τα αυτό χρονα να υποφελίς
τα θετικών τουρισμό και το κομμάτι που οιδικά τους χημερινούς μήνες και τοσιδων είναι κάτι
που είαι να εκροκαι παρά πολλαξιοιακλίνου να δημουργάς διαθνούς αγόνες να τους φέρνεισ τα νιώτες
στην κύπρο που από μελετι που γίνει και προσφατα από τη βηλαμρά που πιάστα χέρια
μου ιβήλά μόρα στην πορτογαλία είναι ένας χόρες που εποποφελήθηκα πάρά πολύ μετοκ εκανα παρά
πολλους αόνες και εχει νκιπλέο ενα γκέντρο που πάν παραπολύ κι κάνουν αγόνες και προπονηση
και κάναμια αν έρευνα και ρίχνο ότι το οικονομικών υπακπου έχει κάθε φορά που είνατα
ένας αγόνας είναι περίοπου αναμης ε κατομύριο ένας μεγάλος αγονας το σπέντι και τώα τα
έξωατων αγωνιζόμενο καιτων προπονητών τους που ία απλά ει διαμονί διατροφή στο χώρο εφαντάσουν τώρα
να κάνουμε δύο ετρεις αγωνες το χρονώ αναμιλάς να να έρχονται να ξωεύουν τασραμε βέντε
εκατομύρια στονισί μας κάθε χρόνο και τες πιο πολλές φορές σε όύσιζον μιλμές που είναι
ένα α κομμάδι αυτόν ρα το σκεφτομε έτσι πιο λοκληρωμένα ευπάρχουν παρααπλαβαον πραπούμε παρακάάλκάποιαάα έχει
τους στόχους του απλά θελάσε ις οκάτι μετά τους ολινδιακούς λγές μέρες μετά είχε κάποια
παράπονα ο πάύνος υπυρξαν κάποιες επιστόλες προς τον πρόεδρο της κυπριακής ις τοπλογής ομως πνδίας
επιλήθηκε αυτό το πρόβλημα ήρθα κάποιοι άλλι αρμοδι φορίς να σου πουν πάύλο τιείναι αυτά
τα παράπονα από έχεις απτηνομό πονδία σου θα